chers amis
je suis très heureux de d'avoir quelques
minutes pour m'adresser à vous ce matin
après ces deux jours ensemble ou la
famille s'est réunie
je crois et je peux le dire au nom des
députés du groupe présent ici c'est du
jour ont été enrichissant
intellectuellement bien sûr tous les
échanges et les débats que nous avons eu
humainement aussi parce que être à
Guidel
c'est avant tout le plaisir de se
retrouver les militants de notre coin
mais d'ailleurs d'échanger les uns avec
les autres
alors que dire de l'année qui vient de
s'écouler mes collègues députés pourront
témoigner c'est une année où il a fallu
s'adapter en permanence avec une
majorité
qui n'est que relative et font tirer les
conséquences
cela oblige d'abord à être présent du
lundi au vendredi souvent avec des
heures de missiles où l'on entend hurler
la plus perd du temps des inépsies
fréquemment ou je dois vous dire
quelquefois il faut s'accrocher à son
siège pour pas sortir de ses goûts
certains dit ailleurs y arrivent
parfaitement d'autres un petit peu moins
je pense qu'ils sont reconnaîtront
comme
président de groupe je suis
assez fier d'être au milieu d'un groupe
qui je crois est respecté
j'ai pour habitude de dire que notre mot
d'ordre c'est une forme de sérénité
active
je voudrais lui dire aux militants vous
pouvez être fier de votre groupe d'abord
parce qu'il est très mobilisé nous
sommes aussi forces de proposition sur
tous les textes
je ne veux pas en faire la litanie mais
Erwan par exemple apporter des textes
importants et dans l'actualité hélas sur
le harcèlement scolaire
notre groupe est à la place à laquelle
il doit être
véritablement centre même physiquement
de l'hémicycle loin des outrances des
extrêmes mais toujours prêt à écouter et
à discuter les propositions d'où
qu'elles viennent
quittent les amender du moment que nous
sommes totalement justes
cette nouvelle configuration donc nous
oblige vis-à-vis de nos partenaires de
renaissance et horizon avec lesquels
nous échangeons quotidiennement et ça
marche bien je peux vous l'assurer et
bien sûr avec le gouvernement nous
sommes loyaux c'est très clair et
personne ne pourra nous dire le
contraire
nous le sommes parce que nous croyons en
ce que nous faisons
plus de 45 textes ont été adoptés lors
de la cession dernière
d'importance variable il faut le dire et
oui quelques 49-3 sont passés par là
aussi avec des notions de censure
systématique de la part de l'opposition
repoussée à chaque fois et je dois
saluer Anne qui nous représenté vendredi
soir lors de la plus récente d'émotions
de censure qui n'a bien sûr pas été
adopté
le position parle de coup de force en
permanence et que font-ils pour nous
permettre et permettre à notre pays
d'aller de l'avant il refuse tout
tout y compris des plans de relance les
aides aux Français les plus démunis
certains clairement ne sont pas là pour
construire mais uniquement pour
s'opposer
avec ces 49-3 absolument nécessaires sur
les textes financiers notre méthode de
travail a évoluer nous devons
systématiquement travailler en amont
avec le gouvernement pour faire passer
nos idées le 49-3 est aussi un coup près
pour les groupes de la majorité puisque
le gouvernement choisi seul ce qu'il
décide de conserver dans le texte nous
avons donc vraiment tout intérêt à
négocier en amont
ce que nous faisons d'ailleurs les
journaux ces derniers jours ont relaté
quelques frictions en cours avec Bercy
sur certaines de mes idées qui ont pu en
hérisser certains mais qui en ont réjoui
d'autres je me demande d'ailleurs s'il
n'y a pas une forme de conflit
génération au vu des interpellations que
j'ai pu avoir d'ici là
les jeunes sont beaucoup plus réceptifs
que les plus âgés sur par exemple l'idée
d'une taxation européenne au CDE mondial
pour aider nos sociétés à s'adapter et
préserver notre planète et bien sûr
notre devoir être préparé l'avenir il y
a beaucoup de jeunes ici et c'est
important sur l'environnement
particulier et le débat que j'ai pu
avoir avec Pierre larouture ou hier a
montré je crois que nous devons tous
travailler pour trouver des solutions
pérennes se sentir responsable de
l'avenir très pragmatique et prospectif
sur ces enjeux doit être notre marque de
fabrique pour construire la société de
demain
cette année a été aussi une année où
nous avons renforcé nos liens avec nos
collègues de l'Union centriste et avec
le président Hervé Marseille que je
voudrais remercier à la fois pour sa
présence avec nous aujourd'hui mais
aussi
pour notre beau travail en commun sur
pas mal de textes
sachez-le notre groupe a passé une belle
année très riche les nouveaux élus que
je veux saluer ici prennent désormais
toute leur place les plus anciens
partages leur expérience tout cela
fonctionne très bien une nouvelle
session s'ouvre demain et nous sommes
tous prêts à nous y investir pleinement
riche de nos débats et de notre ADN
beaucoup de sujets nous attendent pour
consolider notre modèle français pour
continuer à créer la richesse au profit
de l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pour
prendre soin de tous vous pouvez compter
sur nous je vous remercie et j'appelle
Hervé Marseille à monter la télé